well a unlv student is really breaking
barriers making waves in the world of
science yes we're talking about sit loli
lopez the first at the university to be
awarded a 20 thousand dollar research
fellowship joe mohler has her story
and i do enjoy the experimentation
itself a few days a week you'll find sit
lolly lopez in this unlb lab i did lose
a few family members like an aunt who
was really healthy to cancer she is
working on a research project i really
want to help as much as i can it's
research on a compound for a possible
drug that would slow the growth of
cancer because i really want to get
towards that end goal because i know how
useful it could be in preventing the
growth of cancer the las vegas native
was the university's first ever
recipient of a 20 thousand dollar pfizer
diversity research fellowship i did
think it was like very competitive and
i'm like i don't think i stand a chance
the mexican-american student is one of
the first in her family to go to college
generally male students are
working in sinterkorgan chemistry field
her professor jun young kang says this
highlights the importance of diversity
in chemistry having uh the
diversity students in our group what is
beneficial for us is that we can have
different mind so that we can can we can
have different ideas from various
aspects and background so that we can
come up with a different new idea to
tackle the problems that we have now she
is making a difference for the latino
community and breaking down gender
barrier like i was told often like maybe
you should try being a teacher maybe a
secretary she hopes her work done in
this lab not only makes a difference for
cancer-related research but also for her
community and young women who want to
pursue a career in science just do
what you feel is right and you will do
well lopez will graduate from unlv next
year and she does have plans to go to
grad school as for the drug research she
is conducting here she will present her
findings to pfizer this summer reporting
on the unlv campus joe muller live local
now